Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right, what's going on guys.
This is Rob and we are back with the conclusion of Marvel zombies, resurrection,
right? This wraps up the whole thing.
And what we do here is we kind of start off a little bit ago and essentially
what's left of the superhero community, right?
Even just super hero and super villain community, right?
So you've got miles Morales. You've got Bucky Barnes. You got Dr. Strange,
you've got electro, right? Spider-Man villain well-known Spider-Man villain.
You've got these different characters who were here and seemingly out of
nowhere, they're met by the arrival of Spiderman,
who of course has Valeria Richards and Franklin Richards in tow.
So this is during the initial outbreak here.
Now the truth is that this is kind of cool and this kind of makes sense.
This is where Marvel zombies resurrection could either succeed incredibly well
or fail disastrously so far. The story is not too bad. I mean,
it definitely needs some work and there's definitely some expansion that I think
needs to be done in order to make it make more sense.
But there's a lot of great stories that could be told here, right?
Like everything that was going on during the initial outbreak.
And that's why I say,
I think that Marvel zombies started happening the way that it did as a direct
response to DCC. Right? Then we got the Marvel's Army's return one shot,
and then we got nothing for like a year. And then we get, you know,
Marvel's Army's number one long after DCC has already kind of done its thing.
Right. And basically told us the main story.
And so with Peter Parker in them alive,
and he basically begged anybody to save up Franklin Richards and nobody can
write, not even Dr. Strange, right? He's like, there's nothing I can do here.
I can't say Franklin, but warlock steps up and says, I can save him,
but it won't necessarily be the way that you think. And so again,
picking back up in the modern day,
right now we have Peter and the rest of the heroes who went to the Galactus
hive, right. Where Galactus basically crashed, landed on earth.
That's kind of the first of the infected. So to speak,
carrying all the other infected heroes and then bringing them here. And so with,
with Peter encountering, Mary Jane, of course, she's kind of a,
I'm telling them, Hey, you know, join us that kind of a thing.
And then basically in the middle of nowhere, you know, when,
when Susan goes to bite,
Franklin does suddenly phalanx starts emerging out of Franklin Richards and the
whole shield, everything of Susan storm lets down.
And that's what we end up finding out that the way that Franklin lived is that
this is not actually Franklin Richard's right. It is.
But it's not truly like the, like the true Franklin,
the true Franklin Richards has long since been dead. Right.
He died at the very beginning of the whole thing because he was bitten.
What ended up happening is that warlock use his phalanx ability, right?
So basically it's kind of like techno organic virus kind of ability to basically
create a new Franklin Richard's body.
And then the consciousness of Franklin was moved by Dr. Strange from his old
body into his new body.
And so that's why he doesn't recollect anything that happened.
He doesn't recall being bitten or any of that stuff because he is kind of a
wholly new creative character.
The thing about this is that he's not fully human.
The other part of this is that Valeria once she starts to kind of realize the
way things truly are that our family really can't be saved.
She does what she has to do. And she basically starts killing them. Right.
She starts killing off Ben Grimm and,
and Johnny and Reed and Susan and all them, she basically starts killing them.
All, you know, is, you know, and, and, and sucks, right?
Because she has to annihilate her. The other part of that is that chewy,
the cat, who of course can swallow huge amounts of stuff,
ends up spitting back up a bunch of the robots that,
that in a previously swallowed when they were in the machine city.
And so it's kind of a, you know, ad hoc reinforcements, right.
And things are happening super fast here.
And of course that basically leads to Peter accepting the fact that Mary Jane is
not actually his girl anymore.
Eliana Rasputin tries to go toe to toe with blade. And of course, you know,
she kind of gets the upper hand on him to a degree,
of course doesn't necessarily kill him.
But when she goes in for the killing blow Wolverine,
finally re-emerges and then cuts off the head of Eliana Rasputin as well.
That's when Valeria is like, we have to get to the Galactus hive.
We have to get up there as fast as we possibly can.
And so Peter leaves Mary Jane behind. And once they get to the,
to the Galactus hive itself, or at least as they try to make their escape manna,
the Sentinel kind of ends up giving them a ride.
But Nana isn't really able to make it as fast as she can, right.
Because she's basically had a whole bunch of damage done to her systems.
And so in their current condition, it's the fastest she can go,
but it's not working because everybody's catching up to them. Right?
All these people are traveling as fast as they possibly can to seize everybody
here.
And so what ends up happening is Hannah actually discharges her arms and sends
the rest of them flying into Galactus hive. And then she's ultimately destroyed.
Now, once they get there,
the big ones I ask here is what do they do now that they're in the Galactus
hive? What do they do in this situation? Is it simple? Is it more difficult?
Like how does all this work? And so what we end up getting is,
is Valeria basically saying like, I need two minutes.
And that's when the silver surfer intervenes.
And it makes perfect sense that he would for surfer Reno as a former Hill of
Galactus, what basically remained inside of Galactus white.
We're just kind of stay there as a kind of safety 50 device.
And you get this amazing moment between Franklin Richards and the surfer, right?
The Franklin literally uses his warlike abilities and just send us like pins,
a surfer against the wall. And when the server calls his board,
he takes the sort of,
of magic of Ileana recipe and the sole sword and cuts the board in half. Right.
And then just loses. It just says, like, you guys killed everybody,
you killed porridge, you killed uncle Ben, you killed uncle Johnny,
you killed Nanak, you killed everyone.
And Franklin takes the full totality of the soul sword and slice a silver surfer
in half and basically kills it. Now, one thing to understand here,
and I think it's kind of smart that Marvel did this.
This is not the full totality of Franklin's pouch, right?
He doesn't really have his reality warping abilities anymore because seemingly
his abilities were tied to his body. Now, in all truth,
it shouldn't be work that way.
Unless you have something like a healing factor or something along those lines,
your powers are not tied to your body.
Your powers are tied to your mind's ability to control something.
That's why that that bit is important.
There it's how individuals like to beyond,
or that has no true physical form can still do the kind of things that he does,
right. The beyond her takes on a physical form.
But the beyond her is essentially just living energy with somebody like Alexis.
He's the exact same way. If you saw Galactus in his true form, he would,
you would just be a swirling, massive energy in a giant purple suit.
And that would be yet, right. So Franklin, his ability to,
to do what he can do is not tied to his physical body.
So by all standards of measurement,
even having his consciousness transformed or moved to a new body should still
mean that he can alter reality on a universal scale,
but such as it was Phillip Kennedy, the guy writing this story kind of,
but when would the idea that Franklin's ability to utilize his powers are tied
to his physical form, right?
And so that's why he's not really able to use reality warping on a massive
scale, at least not that we've seen. Now,
the other part of this of hilarious plan that what she's doing here is she's
basically using the power of gambit.
And that this hand that she has in her possession was taken by a,
take it by Remy LaBeau, taken by gambit, by force himself.
And the Ford would use it as a kind of source of energy.
What she's doing here is literally channeling the power of gambit into the heart
of Galactus and the intention it's a completely and totally destroyed.
And so Valeria tells Franklin, get everybody out of here as fast as you can,
right? The sword will know what to do. The sword will know how to get them away.
And so what it is up doing is whisking away, Franklin blade, the cat, Wolverine,
you know, everybody here, right? Everybody hears here,
Spider-Man Valeria herself. They all get teleported away just as galoshes.
His entire physical form is destroyed by, uh, by the hand of, of gambit.
Now here's the funny thing about this is that technically speaking gambit could
do this. Gambit could kill Galactus.
And the reason why is because Gavin's ability is to basically charge up
potential energy, to take potential energy, turn it into kinetic energy,
to basically take objects that are in rest and put them in motion exceedingly
fast, and to force them to spontaneously combust.
There are some limitations depending on, on what we're talking about here,
but we're also talking about this particular universe.
So we don't really know if gambit in this universe under what the same kind of
Labonte process that he did in the main Marvel universe, which use his powers.
The fact that he's powerful enough to destroy Galactus would seem that that's
not the case, that he actually never underwent that process.
And that there's no limit to the power that he has.
The other part of this though,
is that gambits limit in terms of his ability to destroy objects is truly
limited by his mind because of the fact that his mind was altered to restrict
how much of his power he could use.
And so if you have a person who can utilize the power of gambit without any of
the blocks that gambit has in his mind and seemingly they could destroy
Galactus, right? There's as many questions being left unanswered here,
as there are questions being answered here,
but Galactus in the entire hive are completely and totally destroyed, right?
So in effect the heroes,
basically the one here as to what we end up doing is picking up a month later
with manna being rebuilt by the combined efforts of Valeria alongside Vivian,
right? The daughter of vision, and with a, with blade,
actually training Franklin on how to use a sword.
The question kind of comes down to what comes next.
And what will rain talks about is actually reopening the savior school, right?
Reopening the school. And because there's still mutans out there,
even though they're in hiding, there's still meetings out there.
They still have their powers and the X-Men still need to exist.
So it was kind of reforming the team,
even if only helping to combat whatever forces happened to exist out there
because not all of humanity has been destroyed.
Not all of humanity has been defeated.
And so while there are still meeting survivors, there are still human survivors.
So there's still room there to create stories of like, you know,
mutants against humans and, and different things like that.
But Franklin ultimately ends up leaving, right? Ultimately ends up, you know,
going back inside the house and heading back into his room.
And what we end up finding out here is that he still has the head of silver
surfer because he has questions that he's been reading over the books of Charles
Xavier, specifically in relation to the brood.
And he asks every single brute hive has a queen, right?
So if the brute hive infected Galactus and then in turn,
Galactus was brought to earth when he infected the heroes,
then that means there had to have been a brood queen on earth.
So the question is, who's the brood queen, right?
Who's this person that's in charge of the brood,
this one individual that survived and could repopulate and basically recreate
this entire zombie infection yet again,
only improve on where they messed up before.
And the response is silver surfer is that she knows exactly who you are.
She knows who you are.
She knows what it is that all of you guys did on this earth.
And the two of you will meet soon enough.
And so the indication here is that the brute queen is actually Carol Danvers,
right? The,
she was infected and she's the one that's basically kind of running the show.
So with that being said, guys, we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you guys are new here to come and explain it,
make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light and let me know what you guys thought about.
Marvel zombies down in the comment section. For being honest with the guys,
it's a much lackluster story than the original Marvel zombies.
It's not nearly as good, but, uh, yeah,
we're gonna bring this to an end and I will catch you all later.
[Inaudible].